okay hello everyone welcome to another
water language design review meeting
this is part of our incremental language
development
series
and we've got a variety of topics here
first
cardinal direction string i thought that
was a pretty straightforward thing but
let's see
yeah we started talking about it last
week and we wanted to continue a bit um
yeah the the basic idea again being take
an angle on a compass give a direction
string um
under that item there i have a
graphic that shows kind of the different
granularities you can return
hold on why is this 51 as opposed to 51
degree
is this something where we think it's
like bearings
i mean for example in the geo stuff
bearings are given just in numbers but
they represent degree bearings is that
correct
yes that's correct
for example in travel directions
do we have a bearing and traveled you
know if we say turn
go east on i-97 or something i think
there is an i-97 but yeah
do you know what i'm saying do we say
not there but for example in your
destination
you can specify the direction
just using a number
and it will interpret it as
degrees what about a thing with units a
quantity object
right there we should follow the units
given
okay fine but so cardinal direction
string would take a quantity object as
well as a naked number
right yeah
and um
okay
granularity are you asking the question
what
uh so there's a hidden image under that
granularity question there that shows
the different degrees to which you can
break down
we have our primary cardinal directions
and then the
and then the people with smaller hats
yeah less cardinal never mind
and this somewhat relates to the the
next section which uh sander had linked
in the last stream he has a generalized
dms string function that
there are different versions of you know
do i want
n as a string versus north versus
and then w versus north northwest we
probably want a second argument but what
we you know what do we want well i mean
look if we're going to do this we've
also got the same issues as we have with
integer string which is that there's
internationalization because we've got
names here right like i'm quite certain
that in in um you know it's
or whatever it is or aust or something
in um
you know
probably where sander is
um
um
let's see
so
these are called compass roses or four
of four wins eight wins 16 wins 32 wins
yeah so perhaps what we need is some
sort of second argument in which we
specified in there how windy it should
be what the exactly yeah
um
well it's basically a granularity
specifier and it could be
yeah i mean it's going to be that and
it's got to be i mean it's very similar
to internet name isn't it i mean you
know because it's got to be that and
it's got to be things like
um
what the uh
you know like like how this is
now presumably there's also is it an
icon data or somewhere else where we
actually have something which is like a
control that shows one of these things
with a particular direction picked out
yes so there the last point in this
section under related utility compass
direction actually shows the icon
generator
which i don't believe is in icon data
currently but probably should be
okay
all right let's not spend too long
because this is really shouldn't be okay
what is this now
this is this is an interpreter
exactly
why don't we just put it as an
interpreter why isn't an interpreter
it could be so right now the
geofunctions can understand all these
strings and they would interpret them
via this function
i see okay fine but we could package
this
as a
as an interpreter
yep
okay but now
um
in
you know for some reason cardinal
direction string
it's just a very ponderous name i mean
it just somehow
um
what is an alternative to cardinal
direction is it like
compass string or something or
bearing i mean i don't know what these
things are called bearings
go ahead
yes we could actually uh call it geo
direction string
oh that's a good idea
that seems more sensible yes
um
so is that wait a minute what is geo
direction
the direction takes right now two
locations
and it gives the bearing that you have
to follow from the first one to reach
the second one
so it's a different concept but it
gives
the it gives an angle also
its output is an angle
exactly
and it's the same angle that these
strings would be converted to
so an angle from north
clockwise in degrees
what's our precedent for something where
it's x
and then an x string i mean until we
have integer and integer string which do
very different things
integer being the object itself the head
of the object itself and it's just
string being the stringified you know
date string
date object date object yeah
what do other people think about geo
direction string
christopher do you have an opinion
i think it's okay it's a little bit
niche but
yeah
it is niche but we don't really have a
um i mean this whole piece of
functionality is a little bit niche so
such as life yeah i agree
um
but i don't see how to package it with
anything else i mean like the
interpreter we can package other stuff
but
you know
um
uh
let's see
um
okay
go
an advantage of using geodirection
rather than cardinal direction is that
there are other names of the winds i
mean there are actual names for the
winds like
libeccio and things like that so we
might have
a second argument in which we say we
find actually
yeah except
so we can then either have an integer
which is the wind number like eight wins
or something
um
and
the default i mean if you say 51.73
you're not going to get some giant
string presumably
we'll have a default
exactly i think the standard is is the
the strings that you see on these
compass rules
okay
and we could expand it we could have
some sort of long version like we do
with dates things like that yeah i mean
this
yeah
so that's west bank where is south by
southwest
no dubai is so it's always um a single
sir
oh so i see so south by southwest is a
fake the conference that is
fascinating
yes so the bi is the
direction in which you modify it a bit
yeah i understand that i understand that
but i'm just amused that the conference
is a fake direction
um
yeah this seems not controversial but
the cl the second argument could either
be granularity or it could be this
format where you specify
you know
the the obscure more obscure names or
the localization or whatever well but
why don't we just combine them i mean i
think we're doing that kind of thing
with interesting name
okay
yep
you could have that in a list
okay so the one remaining thing is is
sanders
dms string
um
you know
it's a little weird that we have dms
string and then we have this
then we have this name thing
presumably by the way the name thing can
eat a dms string
right yeah
i mean dms is what we're calling this
is there any other name
well i guess degrees minutes seconds
could apply to things other than geo
stuff
whereas this north south thing is pretty
geo-specific right yep
specifies one of the cardinal directions
that's a sub case of dms string
yes that's to hand that's to specify how
to handle the sign
yeah but it's committing to south things
like this
yes you have to specify whether you are
interested in east west or north south i
know that but i mean it could be the
word south and all kinds of other weird
stuff like this yes i think that's what
sander is generalizing
well
i i know we shouldn't take more time on
this right right this second but it
seems like
um
we can generalize this a bit i haven't
explored sanders function but
fine i i will see let's look at that
okay any more to figure out about this
oh
and we'll put it in icon data
that comes
i i mean this is something continuous
this is more like a little gauge
not that it can be controlled but
well icon data allows you to specify
like icon data
doesn't the moon phase thing how does
icon data work with them with things
that can be controlled
oh i see i i see
there it is i see okay okay
i thought it was fixed icons yeah yeah
oh
okay yeah so then we can do something
something like this
yeah i think wind direction is already
somewhat similar to that yeah
yes it is so we just have to have a
compass
icon data of compass or something and we
could have i mean this is a a tim
kind of thing we should have some kind
of indicator
icon data indicator that draws a
direction on one of these compass roses
yeah
yep
okay
all right
should we move on
yep
george
so this next section was a discussion
that was started on
uh tdash ild um brad had some
comments about it but the basic idea
was should we have a standalone inverse
bool function or should we have some
self-inverting bool function
the general consensus was we obviously
can't change anything that bool does
because it's a function that's been
around for ages we don't
i
don't think we want bool of one
returning
true
[Music]
well what does pool of one do right now
nothing nothing yeah i don't think that
is absolutely impossible the bull of one
could return true
we never thought of that before we did
discuss inverse pool
well um
that's the one that i implemented for
some code that i was writing and it's
it's actually on the agenda there i just
called it tf01
except that i went ahead and did
something crazier by switching the zero
and the one
but
the
the if you want to change bool from
doing nothing to doing something
there's two alternatives i guess is
either making bool item potent
or
making it self inverse
and the problem with the self-inverse i
think
is this that
at least one person said was horrifying
is that you can have a mixed list
of
you know boolean true false and integer
zero one oh god and i see and it goes
well and it flips everything in the list
but bool of one does nothing
yeah and i don't you know yan was also
on this thread with some interesting
examples and
the one that he gave
it looks really bad
if you
make bool item potent
he said
so that if you have bool of like
you mean to type bool of x equals equals
one
but then you accidentally type bool of x
equals one
well if bool is
then it's gonna really
you know okay
look okay so listen the hackery of bool
of boo you know bool of one giving true
is probably not on the in the cards
anyway
so then the question is is a frambool
uh i mean to my defense the code
works with the inverse thing but i
unders totally understand if most people
don't want to do it that way okay but
hold on we got we've got two things here
there's a couple of different pieces of
functionality the relevant here
you know
the idea of
um
you know
i have increasingly started doing
yeah i mean i don't know how common this
is you know something like this
right there's a way
that's sort of a
generalization
now i'm totally confused no no i think
you're i think what you're doing is
making sense of like if it's just a
conversion problem uh over a finite
alphabet or something like that then it
should really just be a lookup
but the the other thing that's in the
documentation for bool
is that you can convert back by saying
like
uh making a logical function that
outputs true or false
so if you have one equals equals number
or something like that
what i
mean down into into you know it does
basically some sort of replace all
doesn't it which is sort of its whole
point
yeah but it's at least also just
listable
yeah
but if you
but if you go to the documentation for
bool and then see like uh
there should be somewhere in the
examples and inverse like probably under
properties and relations
investible
yeah so that's that's like a functional
way to do it but that's actually for
this problem not what i would first
think okay okay okay look
to me
the serious possibility is to have a
function from
boolean the concept of inverse bull is
just absolutely horrifying and we're not
gonna you know that just doesn't make
any sense
um
so
you know
funky thing about going from bull is
that
it it kind of seems to me like
well
yeah i mean it seems like like
the the the
the expression like trues and falses are
like like the strict sort of correct way
of representing booleans and zeros and
ones are kind of thing yeah you want to
know what from two does
that would be one problem yeah
doing on the live stream is pointing out
that he uses
i don't know that worked wow look at
that
what do you know
it's positive listable or i assume it
doesn't drill down like pool does
it might be listable i'm not sure
i don't think it is i think i think it's
it's a single predicate
but i'm wrong
well you don't know you're wrong until
you put a negative thing into it but
hopefully you're you're wrong what why
doesn't this one have a q on it
what what's the difference between
positive and positive q
there isn't a positive q
um predicates also aren't there's an end
in q because it doesn't always evaluate
um okay so maybe we should just add
positive to the documentation page no no
it's a hack
no it's a pretty good hack though
right but
right but once you can i mean this this
is one of the other issues is that bool
only recognizes trues and falses and it
ignores everything else in the
expression
but this inverse you know from bool or
whatever the question is does it only
see zeros and ones or like in the pool
documentation does it also see twos and
threes because if it sees twos and
threes it's it's harder to know what
exactly it seems
yeah oh one suggestion i thought of just
based on the use case that i was doing
if you wanted to do from bool for the
integers
you could actually just make it do true
or false what integer digits does over
base two
so then you get
confusing it is confusing but that's
what we do in practice
okay look look
first point is okay
okay i've got a couple of levels of
question okay from bull just with zeros
and ones
seems
highly safe
you know
if you really want to cut it down i mean
again i'm not a big fan of this hackery
but i mean you know sign
is a common way to cut things down to
the zero one case
but i think that you know the cutting it
down to the zero one case
is potentially dangerous because you
might have a you know a
entity representing a turtle there and
do you want that to be a zero or one
well even with sine what is from bool of
minus one
well i know i know
i know so
i mean i think there's an argument that
from will be a very trivial function
that just takes 0 1 and turns it into
true false
just as a code convenience so to speak
comments from people i mean is there a
better name than from boole
i always have to think for a moment
which way round does bool go
same
i was thinking of one queue
if you say one q then if then two should
give zero i should get false
yeah
i don't think that's
convincing uh
another question i had was whether or
not
bool does anything more than just
convert
um from zero one to true false
the pool converts from two false to zero
one oh right right but does it do
anything more than that
no i don't think so
so then the then basically we're looking
at is
adding two similar functions which have
basically two tiny little operations
that they do yeah that's right but bool
is a super useful function
i'm really glad we have it
otherwise a lot of code
would just be much much much messier
right like that piece of code
is very nice with bull
oh right but you can you know the
alternative is just saying like if i i
know i'm well aware i'm well aware okay
but but that's the whole point we that
we have a function so we don't have to
do that
so similarly here
um
yeah i mean it would be a convenience
for this other code that i was writing
to have the yeah yeah let's let's just
look look look look look
the fact is bool
the thing that's really screwy here
is that often when you think of a
boolean it is true or false
whereas we have the function bool that
takes
true false
and does what old george boole did
of identifying true and false with zero
on one
you see what i'm saying
well actually just for context i mean
does does the function bool have some
you know
is this a known you know function in in
math or other computer science or is
this just our name that's named after
george
it's named after george and it was
actually suggested by the george
long time george at our company back
um
well he missed the opportunity to try
and name the function george
yes
the um
but uh
uh
wait but there's no there's no there's
no sort of
no
there are names yeah there are there's
things like the indicator function is a
common name for something like this
which is just utterly obscure
um
i have no idea what the inverse
indicator function is
if there is an s1
well i think the in indicator function
is compared to
uh floor and ceiling and i was thinking
a little bit about that analogy that
it's really not like floor and ceiling
it's more like
a trig to x and
x to trig
yeah
yeah but i mean look
look the fact is
okay christopher was asking is there no
name in math for this concept and the
answer is there are some names but
they're really
bad and bull is a much less
i mean the only thing that's bad about
bull is that you kind of think of it
like
it's giving a boolean which in you know
when we named this
i don't think it was as common to have a
boolean type so to speak
i mean for me the main advantage of bool
is how short it is
it's easy to type yeah yeah yeah right
yeah well okay so look
from bool
i feel like in rule is a better name
than from bool because the other from
functions the second word is what it
takes but this doesn't take a bull it
takes a zero or one i don't know it does
take a bull that's the whole point
that's what our bull okay
history
in this context two thousand years
people have been talking about true and
false
george boole in the
1830s 1840s
[Music]
uh
40s maybe i've forgotten um you know had
this brilliant idea if we can make an
algebra out of logic by making by
treating true false like zero one for
like one zero
see what i'm saying yeah but much of the
world uh will carl bull uh refer to the
true false as the bulls i know that i
know that it might be a historical error
but it's a historical error but but it's
but it's a universal one so fair enough
so that's a reason for not using from
bool
well one problem with inverse school
though is that well first it sounds the
other functions that we have with
inverse of the names i think are are
more like uh they're more heavyweight
and they're more mathematical
um we've discussed inverse pool before
and i think it's crazy
i don't think anybody calls them bool
right so from bull i don't think seems
we could say that bulls are ones and
zeroes bullies yes because it will still
be confusing and it takes a moment every
time one uses bull one has to think
about
you know which way around
actually like from boolean
which is weird
yes well if you make bools
for the modern for the modern you know
sort of incorrect historical usage of
the term boolean yes
bool is from boolean
bool does what george boole did
and you know aristotle is the one who
should be credited with the you know it
should be aristotle rather than you know
the the the thing that we are now
describing could be called aristotle if
we call the other one bull this one
could be called aristotle but i'm not
seriously suggesting that
so so should it be too boolean
no that's utterly confusing
look what it is is
to true false that's what it really is
well maybe this this raises another
another uh
thing which is which is that we don't
have i don't i'm not sure we ever use
the term boolean like we don't have a
boolean q
which is sometimes a little bit annoying
yes we do right otherwise you'd say two
boolean oh
never mind
okay i thought we didn't
i've just unnecessarily been writing
true or false
we don't have a pattern we don't have a
pattern for
it like you know
right sure integer
yeah because they have head symbol
and what happens if we have an
expression that simplifies to one but
it's not explicitly one
i'm thinking of possible zero q and
whether we will have the same type of
problem
well it does help that boolean algebra
is decidable
i mean if it's purely logic expressions
we can resolve them
the input to this function
like algebraic expression could be like
polynomials
what to boolean queue
you know to
from bool inverse pool whatever
i think it should just look for the
expression
one you know
the integer one
anything else that's going to be kind of
in in trouble
especially if it's sort of thought of as
a
inverse to bool
what about to true false
it's awfully long for something which is
basically just if
one then true
you know blah blah blah equals equals
one basically
it's more characters than blah blah blah
equals one
yeah
it's also i think the name kind of
implies that it it does clever things
too like there are different formats it
might take
okay
well
one other observation is that
even though people don't like the
suggestion of making bool book two ways
it does eliminate the problem of not
knowing which way it goes
i agree with that that is a good point
let's review that possibility for a
second what goes wrong if we make bull
two way
i don't think anything will go wrong but
what people have said is that they're
worried about
more
output errors because of having mixed
types because if you if you just do the
tf01 function that's there
you can it will evaluate that
and the evaluation just goes to well
since it's inverted it goes to false
zero false
true
okay i would like us to study the
possibility because i i would love to
not be confused about whether
um
it could be a problem for the compiler
people not being able to reason about
the type
christopher
i don't think you have a problem with
that
well i i think
things like bool are already a little
bit like
yeah
it's probably fine it's just the problem
of if you if if you had a case where you
can't reason about the type then you
wouldn't be able to construct that input
anyway so
all right let's consider this possible
here i never really we never thought
about this before that bull
then becomes the two-way bull thing
i i think roger and adam might have an
opinion about this they might be
horrified but i don't think they will be
because i think it's it's going to be
it's just basically a converter
yeah and roger and adam might be excited
about it because it it makes some of the
calculations with the sat solver
is that's where i think the use cases
would be
that's where the use case was already
yeah i mean basically i like this idea
because i mean then then if you say
because we've got things like boolean
table okay
so let's just look at this for a second
boolean table pq
okay
okay now this
if we say bool of that
didn't know bull was listable i should
have known that
um
so then and is times right so if you do
table of
what is it p times oh that should be p
yeah yeah yeah but but that's but wait a
second
the
um
well i like the idea of pool being being
this two-way converter i think that
would solve forever this problem of not
knowing which way round it goes and i
think it's useful and i don't really
think it's harmful
so let us explore that let's look at it
with respect to these other boolean
functions
you know i really do think this could be
quite useful because if you look at the
other boolean functions
oh gosh
why does this not point to any boolean
stuff
it really should because this doesn't
operate on boolean
i know that's the other thing it does
the opposite
okay so a boolean function here
does this boolean function thing work on
i don't think it works on ones and zeros
that's what you're asking that's what
i'm asking yes
um
you know could i also ask that somebody
fix this documentation says the nth
boolean function in k variables because
i am so used to seeing cellular automata
turing machines and other things with
the number of variables being with with
the
oh that's not even right
never mind never mind forget that well i
just hate the fact that we're using k
there because i'm just so used to seeing
that as a number of colors
anyway
30 comma 3
okay so now this right now takes true
false
right
and if i were to say
bullying table
this bull thing is not going to help me
this this new bull
the question is the new bull would i
mean that would convert from
a binary function into a boolean
function
i think
yeah i i know well actually if you eat
the question is this question is whether
we can take
an expression
the question is is there any way that we
could have the boolean function function
eat ones and zeros
i don't think it does but you might as
well check
turns out it does
actually is another
sort of
yeah do you try giving it either like an
eight or like an x just to check that
it's not doing something like true q on
its inputs
yeah okay wow
yeah i think we fixed this at some point
because we got so fed up with it not
being just
bone-headed about it oh yeah it's
written you can see it's written there
on details
it's the fourth bullet point
well you know i was going to say
it would be a little horrifying but it's
also maybe relevant for if we wanted to
have boolean functions that work for you
know three valued logic or like n valued
logic
yeah i'm also a little bit unhappy that
this doesn't return zero
but it doesn't take ones and zeros and
to return zeros rather than returning
true and false yeah that makes more
sense
well i i don't know i think it should be
strict in what it returns
yeah but that that is strict in what it
returns
but what if you give it some ones and
some truths and falses or or whatever
it should break probably
can you do that right now
yes i think we tried that didn't we no
we didn't we didn't try mixed well it'll
probably work because you saw what it
did actually in the case where you gave
it a three is it actually produced a new
boolean function that only took one
argument and applied it to three
which is a very fancy thing to do oh
really oh yeah
oh i see the functions represented by
blue and function always return true or
false where we've cooked that goose
all right listen i think bull should be
the two-way thing let's see whether that
see there's anything crazy that happens
consult with these other people let's
give that a try okay let's move on we're
ready to move on
yes sounds good to me a random date
right uh so we talked about this a
couple weeks ago there's a rough page we
can look at um but basically in putting
it together we had a couple of design
decisions to make and i think we've
settled on something that's
pretty good but we wanted to run them by
you
you know in this family of random blah
what are we missing we've got random
points we've got random what are we
missing we've got random color we got
random word
what else do we not have
we don't have random quantity but i'm
not sure how we'd parameterize that
you could give it a specific unit but
then it's just a random value you could
give it a unit what else are we
forgetting
we have random graph but maybe not
random directed and graph
or direct we just do directed edge
arrows are true
yeah oh but it has a whole bunch of
graph distributions so you just have to
write a link we have a whole category in
the function repository called random
stuff double entendre intended
uh
that people have submitted
uh i don't know
right
yeah a lot of them are
are you know
fun
um anti-simplify is a good good one yeah
yeah it's that it's satire
uh
but yeah some of these are out of
fortune
yeah yeah that's random matrix why do we
need that i thought we had matrix
distributions
boy there's some fun stuff here random
text what is that
right so it's worse
yeah
random could be it could be a lot more
intelligent but it's useful for like
laura memphis kind of stuff is random
vector basically um you know it
generates a vector where maybe you say
something oh i want a random unit vector
or something like that
type
seems potentially useful although the
only example i can think of is making a
unit vector which is easy to just
normalize
yeah i know there's something that you
know what
yeah and you want to distribute it
uniformly in a sphere not an x and y
sort of thing you know yeah true
i think you want
uh oh yeah steers the the boundary right
yep
we should give this in the documentation
it's not there
and we should make sure we have a
you know
uh
we should use the term random unit
vector
because that's nice that's a nice thing
it's a random
circle
is there a way to take slices of the
sphere or like subsets of the surface of
the sphere
you mean caps
possibly caps or caps or orange slices
or maybe bands
well i mean these are all regions so you
can use random point on them if it does
it should work too
which okay anyway so all right let's
just see if there's any other random
things
random photo
i think that's pulling in from an api uh
this was
yes
this is good these are the kinds of
functions we should have
the um
why is that so slow
why is that so slow what it was doing
there i mean this is obviously a tiny
function
yeah i didn't see the timing on it um
obviously the first time you use it has
to download and cache it
this is really kind of amusing okay
right if i say 10 does it generate 10 of
them
it even does other languages
does it oh so it does
wow i mean i wonder whether it
translates into um
uh i wonder whether it translates the
the cultural does the cultural
translation as well
that's the function repository sometimes
the developer really does
what they care about
that's not usual
i could be wrong but i thought anton is
from belarus
no no no i think he's from bavaria oh
never mind
yeah
anton's bulgarian
he might be originally from somewhere
else who knows the um
okay
uh
i don't think we need this in the
language no we do not
amusing though he did
okay let's just see there any other ones
here something like random split and
random bins those are you know
reasonable things that
are kind of
generic that aren't
just
arrangement
yeah i mean with this lazy stuff
that is another thing that is
potentially you know given a lazy
you know we're talking about lazy
subsets right
and
obviously there's a take on the lazy
subsets but yeah this is a good point i
don't know if nick is here isn't it
clear
no snakes are here
sorry
so confusing that um
the uh
uh okay
um
that's an interesting idea that hadn't
occurred to me before that given a lazy
data structure
its random part makes sense
see what i'm saying
random parts
you've got you've got a lazy subsets
right lazy subsets represents the whole
collection of subsets
so like random derangement if you had
lazy derangements
random part of lazy derangements would
give you a random derangement
yeah but usually the the whole list
have some predetermined order
so what
because you don't know how many elements
it has necessarily yeah you could use
length but but what i'm saying is just
like random variate it's been very
useful to be able to say random variate
of a distribution without having to
worry about oh what are the end points
and what are this that and the other
so what i'm suggesting is
you know just like we have other things
like uh you know
find the minimum element in this lazy
thing
find a random instance of the lazy thing
seems useful just like we might want a
random path through a multi-way graph
for example
anyways
the same as random choice
there's a random part choice which i
think sounds similar to what you
described why is it why is even random
part choice why is it not what you just
said random choice
why isn't wasn't that the right thing
that that the actual thing would be
list of choices
yeah
why isn't it just this
yeah
i think that's the right thing yeah it
kind of would be hard without actually
no no
without knowing the least
beforehand
but if you know it
you basically doing the strict version
of it anyways
well i don't think you're necessarily
right that it's hard i think it depends
what that thing is
if you can analyze the gen i mean it's
an interesting problem to analyze the
generator and see if you can produce
this
right i mean look if if that lazy list
was infinite range
right
if all ranger i don't know how we're
doing that but if it's range or infinity
right and you say random choice of that
that's hopeless that's undefined
yeah
a question math question in the world of
my god oh this is really confused
oh this was sent to me by email
sorry
um
in the world of um of transfinite
numbers and things does this is there
any notation for this random choice of
of of range of infinity
well
how different is that from choosing a
real number between 0 and 1.
oh hold on one second here
ah sorry i'm just saving this somewhere
appropriate i'm gonna save this in the
oh for the random number between zero
and one
one you at least can specify it to some
n number of digits
right yeah
but for the integer
no it's hopeless i mean there's no way
to specify i'm just asking i would have
thought that was a concept that would
have arisen in theory of transfinite
numbers
well maybe you could make like a dynamic
output thing that when you try to choose
a i'm not talking about our design i'm
talking about i'm talking about in the
world of omegas and you know and and
zeros and things like that is this a
concept i bet it's a concept
um this this is already problematic even
what's a random integer between zero and
infinity
i know i know i know that it is not a
commonly i'm saying just like
you know old mr cantor didn't have a way
to des define you know it's a notion of
a transfer i bet this is some
something that's known to like you know
model theorists or something like that
this concept
of you know naming a random variant that
is anywhere
you know that is a random variable
between
you know zero and
who knows what omega or something i'm
just i'm just asking is just a math
general knowledge question
um okay
well from the perspective of listing
digits then i guess that that
calculation would never halt
sure that's correct i mean but
you can already i mean look the the only
thing you can really do in a case like
that is use some distribution
where it's you know it could return
anything but odds are it's going to
return something that's that fits in
your computer's memory and you can
already do that i mean that's just like
a normal distribution no i i know i mean
the the practicality of this is is
clearly not there but i mean
random choice
of a finite but large like lazy subsets
of you know lazy permutations of of
range of 50 or something that clearly
that's a meaningful thing which is in
that case just like random permutation
yeah okay in any case so i i just i just
want to make sure that
and this should be communicated to
whoever's project managing the
multi-computation stuff which is who is
that now is that kristen now christine
yeah
okay just communicate that to kristen
this random choice in the case of lazy
data structures
okay let's come back
go ahead
yeah okay um let's go back to random
date uh
yeah so the the basic design we settled
on at least for the the simple date case
is if you say random date and you give
it a granular date you will get a
instant within the period defined by
that date so if i give it this year i'll
get a random date for this year
and if i give it a day i'll get some
time within the day etcetera you know
either way if you give it a year though
it'll give you a random in a random
instant in the year right i don't think
it's the right thing to give a random
instance i think because it's called
random date
i kind of feel like it should give by
default a day
well but but date objects are used to
represent instance
yes
we do have an option to control the
granularity of the output
okay
arguably it should be
well i actually never mind i was going
to say argument should be the second
argument because that's what data object
does yeah but i guess random functions
also use the second argument for the
number of things
right syntactically we're following the
other random functions i know and you're
having to introduce a horrifying new
option that we don't have for anything
else which is calendar granularity yeah
it is an option we've talked about
having in the past because the other
arguments for a data object
all have an option form and if we
introduce it for this we would
generalize it and it would be
something you could specify in some
places because we have
run into this before with you know i
want to generate a date range and
the output
granularity i want is potentially
ambiguous and right now we infer it
based on the input dates
and being able to what is the full date
granted
it could be date granularity calendar
granularity is generally how we refer to
the granularity because it's
determined by the calendar assist the
calendar system associated with the date
i think that's obscure
okay
um
what about the possibility of an option
called just granularity just like we
have precision although precision isn't
an option is it
i think that granularity is probably not
so horrifying the only question is
whether random date
should be
because otherwise what you would have to
do is you'd say
now and three years from now okay so
it's now the default is
random date in the next three years
basically
yeah so that this is one of the new
things we've added is this syntax of
specifying a quantity and it being
inferred as an offset from
now
yep
and so you can give a sign to say i want
it three years from now or in the past
three years we can also give a pair
okay so and if i say here
random date
and i say 10 dates
oops is this going to work
okay
and now i say for example date object
what happens if i say date object of
that comma day
well the object doesn't thread yeah so
you'd have there's a good reason they
touch it doesn't thread
it's got to take a list of integers
to mean it year month well yes it does
but i mean it knows if it's being fed
dates
otherwise how would you do this
it doesn't if it's being fed dates that
are
that are
represented with lists
i guess there will be a list of of
you know depth 2 though
i think the thing is that
yeah go ahead
so date object takes also absolute times
so if we make it thread it would have to
thread only on date objects
which i think there's a certain argument
for it doing yeah and we
we'd also talked previously about having
a conform dates function to do things
like i have this collection of dates i
want to conform them to a day
granularity or this specific time zone
or this specific calendar
i like that idea
i think that's useful
i mean ultimately
i mean isn't in this kind of if we had
some kind of date array which i know has
been discussed and is you know
maybe not no
right i mean
if we ever whenever we have a mechanism
for representing arrays of dates
efficiently presumably there'll be a
natural way to do this
do which i mean but the conforming
business
if you say date array
and you feed it a list of a kind of
explicit list of dates it can certainly
conform them at the time and it makes
them into a data ray
right in fact it probably has to
yeah yeah
but i think conform dates as a useful i
mean it would go along with conform
images and things like that yep it
worked basically exactly the same way i
think we should do it i think we should
have that function would it like work
deep in an expression
i don't know i don't care
like a data set i mean that could be
useful that could be useful right that
could be used
um
i would say no because the other conform
functions i think just operate on lists
but
i don't know the data set example is
pretty good
okay look the only thing that's
bothering me is this instance versus
some other default granularity
[Music]
generally if something generates things
at a day granularity the function name
is
day so we have all right plus et cetera
fine then then maybe it's
so if i say
we could have a random day also but i
it's obscure it's yeah
is it that it feels so it is
okay so this will generate this is
pretty reasonable
yeah the one other point i have down
there just to look at is um the support
with date intervals we did end up
basically
um
creating a method to do discontinuous
sampling
um
so this actually uses the regions code
because the other random functions don't
take intervals but
you can see that it samples uniformly
across the entire interval accounting
for the discontinuities
magnificent should the other things take
intervals
it's been discussed before and i think
probably but
developer time is kind of the the
question there
like random real for example
yeah i think there's no technical reason
it can't
obviously it's just a question of
i think that should be in the lcc
meeting at some point okay
pass that along at least okay let's take
a look at the rest of this
looks reasonable to me any objections to
any of this
anybody other than date granularity
which i think needs to be changed and
then added to the other date functions
yep okay we can do that and i will work
on uh conform dates in parallel
sounds good
okay onward
so these are some functions that have
been in the queue for years and years
and every time we've looked at them
we've kind of punted on whether we
should actually implement them or not
and we wanted to kind of circle back and
have a more decisive thumbs up or thumbs
down whether it makes sense to have
okay
so these are side effect functions i
mean i do think
that outer sees more use than i might
expect
certainly more than inner i think
oh yeah inner is much more niche
um
i'm not even sure inner really makes
sense because the whole point you need
to then you know you've got to combine
the elements
i agree
okay but the thing that is
you know
the operation that i do a lot
is some variant of this
and i wonder whether we should have a
function that just does this and also
does not have the confusion that outer
has
about whether it goes down a level here
because if i go here
and i say a b
c d
it's going to make something which is
in other words
and and it also has this varex craziness
my question is whether this case of the
list i mean i don't know how commonly
um
yeah go ahead
no i'm saying it's sort of a tangent to
what we're looking for i'm i
i'm not sure
that that makes it
i mean okay the the reason to have a
scan function
is that you don't want to waste the
memory of the whole right yeah no that's
the whole point and that is important or
could be
right the only problem is i'm not sure
that the semantics
of what you
scan over so to speak
would want to be exactly the same
semantics as the as the outer that is
i could imagine for example
well that seems bad but okay i know i
know if it's called scan outer it has no
choice but but i'm saying clearly in the
case of scan it doesn't care about the
sub listing
right because it's pure side effect
so
well there maybe is a question over what
level if it's equivalent to scan of
outer there's a question of what the
level spec of the scan is maybe you can
select it
you know it's defaulted
minus
it's a more obscure level spec because
scan outer would go to the lowest level
at which the outer
was operating so yeah it's sort of a
level minus one or something of
yeah because i mean in this case here
the scan would clearly go the scan would
go over i mean it isn't it's not level
minus one because because this here
it this is it would go at level two it's
the sum of the levels of
it's the
it's the number of elements here
multiplied by that quantity isn't it
well
partly
because you have lists used in two
different ways
here
yeah probably having f in the first
argument is clear
for this example yeah
no no live stream is suggesting scan
tuples
i was going to say scan tuples and scan
subsets
i mean this is this is related maybe to
the laziness stuff we've been talking
about because there is a whole zoo of
these
these functions that often return big
lists
no but these are constructors so the
important thing is to map a function
over them
well i know but the the point is
how to make look
you're sort of mapping it over a somehow
flattened
version
well
yes but but okay here's a claim
this should be done with laziness
in other words outer the only reason
we're worrying about this the only
reason we've been discussing this
is because when you
you know run outer you get
in other words scan over a lazy object
nick do you already have scan over a
lazy object
or at least here
right
yeah
right so what what is basically being
said here is this is a this is a desire
for another couple of lazy things lazy
tuples lazy outer
because if you had lazy outer
again we there's no discussion it's just
a scan over the lazy altar i know i
admit there's a little bit of a
discussion because of the level specs
but i think that that for our first um
cut at this that's the right approach
scan over the lazy
yeah
right i mean
scan
with a lowercase s
since it's not
why isn't it just scan
because you have to create the whole
thing
you can't do that lazily at this point
no i know i know at this point you can't
but
um
yeah that might be a larger discussion
okay but so i think the answer is that
these scan functions should be
you know folded into the laziness
business
people agree
now the only issue there which is also
raised is the possibility of an outer
list
construct
you know there is a generalization of
tuples
go ahead
well i was just gonna say for the outer
lists
i mean first first of all i don't have
much of a problem with the syntax of
outer i think it's it's decently clear
although it is a bit weird and variesy
but also just the term outer is very
intuitive like it is
it is an appropriately named function
and so i think it's already it's not
like sometimes we have functions that
are like this where you know
like some of those examples with through
or something where
there's a there's a common
usage but it's not all obvious that
through is the function that does that
but but outer is really quite clear that
that's the function you'd want that does
this
yes the thing that i end up with is
crazy catenations and so on
in other words let's take this example
here
of that example there
that i end up wanting really
just all those combinations you know a
whatever it is you know i i want two
balls
what do you mean i can do two tuples and
i can't i would not with multiple things
here can i
uh i think you can yeah give tuples a
list of lists
well let's see what happens
so i give this and then i
oops i give that a list get rid of the
two yeah
is that what you're talking about
i was thinking of going down another
level
oh then then you do need outer
but if i went
down another level
i guess i can just yeah the whole point
is i want to go down another level
but then i want to flatten it so that
all i'm getting is pairs well actually
hold on sorry if you just want ax bx a y
b y you know etc
you can just do
tuples map flatten over that first list
that you give the tuples
like just say flat and slash out right
there and i think that's equivalent to
what you're talking about
yes
and i think in general that's equivalent
to what you're talking about but i think
that's a pretty weird case we are
basically telling it ignore the list
structure of the inputs
yeah okay
all right well look i think the basic
point is we should
leave these sky i still think there
might be a thing around outer list out
of list where there is a different
uh packaging of that
but i'm not immediately coming up with
what it should be
you know outer list blah blah comma one
is something i commonly find myself
doing
i i just think that that usually when
adding functions like that is useful
when
this common functionality is hidden away
in some obscure function with a bad name
but it's not
right now yeah i know i understand
although some people would call this
tuples
which is in fact
oh that's exactly what
does
yeah
so we already have this okay never mind
but i hope outer refers to tuples
properly does it somebody just check
that
it's the first c also
fine
all right we solved the problem
okay let's move on so scan is put on
hold pending lazy scanstar is pending
lazy
all right
um
okay
so these two are related functions that
are popular in the function repository
and
they are technically possible using
curry or
operator apply
but because they're kind of referring to
really fundamental functional operations
i wondered if it's worse what does it do
it's basically an operator form of map
at a given level
so that ml function is
map at level map
so it's dealing with the fact that
maps operator form
map of f
that the two argument form of map
is function and target right
and the same with apply
this isn't crazy i mean this operator
form i don't know whether there's any
it probably takes a third argument and
the third argument to the target so it's
just literally the same thing as map but
it's the last two arguments are permuted
it's a little bit funky
it's a little funky but i think it's not
completely useless i mean well
the really obscure thing would be to
make it default to do this
to have the three argument form be the
same order as map
that would be a little insane
are you sure haven't we done that in
some other cases well it just doesn't
have any value you might as well no one
should ever write the three argument
form of this if it's the same as map i
mean you might as well
yeah if they wrote that expression they
should have just written map
yeah well so then maybe it just is a
two-argument function
well but i'm
i guess i mean they might as well for
some stylistic reason they want to swap
the two arguments which i think they
probably should never do
but but but if that were the case i mean
that would be the only argument for
using the three argument form is what
i'm saying
right
these remind me of echo function and
echo label and
is a similar issue of
the operator form syntax not being
available
right there they just use the operator
form they don't have a non-operator form
oh is that right i like echo function i
use it all the time
however the thing that i don't use all
the time is echo evaluation although i
should
don't use it very often actually
i really should use it
what does quiet echo do
stops echoes
oh
i was there was for some reason i was
yeah yeah names and things
i don't know why
the um
i don't know i i feel like
i'm generally a bit skeptical of these
like
really really tiny convenience functions
because i think that they'll you know
it's sort of uh
you know
for for very pro users it saves them a
handful of characters but for people who
don't really know what they're doing
it's just very confusing like what's the
difference why does this exist and and
it just means that people will read the
code they'll be like i don't know what
map level is
possibly
i kind of like this one i mean i i would
like to analyze you know one way we
could be more principled analyzing
something like this is to be able to
look through code and see how often one
would actually use this
it's hard to know
analytically because it's you know
people people might be avoiding using
maps in big you know say composition
chains because it's you know they have
to write it as a pure function
and they might not write it as a
composition
no is this in fact useful in a
composition chain i think it is
yeah i've certainly i've certainly
written the math
with a level spec pure function before
in in composition chains but
yeah
i'm just afraid i mean like for example
there are a lot of contexts where i'll
explicitly not
use what i'm referring to is a
composition chain because there's a
certain obscurity to it i mean there's a
certain like you know this is some crazy
uh
you know
kind of hieroglyphic way to write things
and i'm i'm sort of concerned about
having an operator you know a function
that is just there for usage and
hieroglyphics
this one's what do other people think
about this
i mean i do think it's useful the other
option i was thinking is if there's some
sort of headdress manner to
hack in a level spec to operator forms
that we can't normally use but i think
that's probably the wrong direction to
go i don't see how you can address the
levels but
well it's the same thing as like
operator applied but but you know it
operator applied which is the first two
arguments
this is you know
operator applied prime which switches
second and third oh that's the i mean it
is also presumably the the second
argument of operator reply or curry
applied to whichever it is but to do
this
that is just utterly obscure
yeah it works but it's it's not at all
intuitive
i'm not sure about this one
should it be called something like deep
applied
no
that's even more obscure
or a level map might be better level map
might be better than that level
i mean it's also confusing because
people will be like well you know map
has a level spec why do you need map
level
yeah i like level map better because
it's a noun
it is an operator so it's a thing
not a good point operation
i don't know
let's just see if there's some let's
take the action item from this to be
let's just see if anybody has code where
they if if you notice i try to remember
i bet i won't as i write code am i going
to end up wanting this
yeah we can i can try and do a scan both
of our internal source and something
like the demonstrations project and
see
where's construction this would be a
good example for some of brenton's ast
stuff to be able to find these
be a good good case to see and you find
maps of blah blah blah two and things
i made a
a
resource function that
is very relevant to that ast pattern it
you just give it an expression and it
converts it to the relevant pattern for
brenton's ast so oh that's cool
hey the other point about this is the
other thing we could do here
is change the bracing business for the
two
i mean another thing this could do as a
convenience would be to say
this thing operates specifically at a
particular level um
so well but you don't always want that i
mean
just not you don't always want that i
know but it could have a different
default
there's no way if the default is map
exactly at level two there's no way of
specifying that but level up to two is
there
you could say one comma two
like the
the function that we have right now that
uh
i don't know i think the functions that
we have right now that operate at
exactly a level spec they pretty much
always do that because it's meaningless
for it to operate on up to on like a
range of levels
and i also think we'll just add
monumental confusion
of what this function is
yeah okay
but that's right
um
all right
well good okay i think we should wrap up
here so i'm we're not going to do this
immediately but perhaps we can uh
we'll do some analysis and see yeah if
you have a chance
um
sounds good all right thanks all and uh
see you later
you